ce matin nicolas yves et lugubre et
glacial
la guerre ne semble toutefois pas entamé
le moral d'un homme aimé des habitants
vitaly kim le gouverneur
nous
mais trop
et qu'on retrouvait après three days
gorvello
nette baisse
un tournant vers stop
il lui est pourtant difficile de
communiquer à tous son optimisme
légendaire l'offensive russe est pour
l'instant contenue mais depuis qu'elle a
commencé les cordes 90 soldats ukrainien
32 civils et 6 soldats russes ont été
emmenés ici à la morgue de miku live
ici des corps sont entassés dans chaque
pièce
nicolas il connaît les circonstances de
la mort de toutes ces personnes ont
achevé très sa manière à lui de
supporter
chercher
[Musique]
ici civilisé combattants ennemis sont
rassemblés
à dire
[Musique]
je
n'en doute pas le spin au contrôle déjà
les beaux parce que le sol ou bien aller
à des tâches incluent voyez n'est pas du
dal et qu'il faut pas qu'il allait
allonger déjà le protocole
à la porte de la morgue un père venu
chercher son fils romane soldats
ukrainien mort au combat
l'instrument de russie on est jeune et
relativement faible at that there
is rich et budo
obligé boudent
des camionnettes vienne emmener des
corps
elles ont ramèneront d'autres demain